pamela anderson wasn't even sure she
would ever live to see this day when she
found out she had hepatitis c but
tonight pamela tells our curly steel
house he'd beat the odds and how it
changed her life 20 years ago when i
told me i have c they told me i'd only
live ten years now that i am cured i
feel like i've just got all those twenty
years back
i'm just gonna go for it now i want to
do every single thing i can don't
life-threatening virus was once
incurable but Pamela says thanks to a
new drug clean bill of health how did
you react when you heard that that's
been an amazing amount of energy already
at your hotel was three months treatment
for Hepatitis I was very tired I slept a
lot about ten years in they said that
you could live your whole life with this
disease and you could get liver cancer
and you could all these horrible other
things Thursday last week I took the
test and Friday they told me I was cured
Pam has always lived her life to the
fullest just consider her marriage to
rocker tommy lee after a whirlwind
four-day courtship back in 1995 Sammy
Tunes him we want her babies yes you
think you're a rock-and-roll mom but
you're not you're quite traditional and
your sons are so well brought up I got
some good Canadian roots in them got
through out of LA as much as possible
Brandon is 19 Dylan is 17 my kids are
academics there are incredible math
students how they understand the
decisions we made at Tommy and I which
is really funny I guess looking at Tommy
and I and us being you know strict
parents we are the couple divorced in
1998 Pam 48 now was just 25 for her ET
debut talking about being discovered at
a Canadian football game oh my god I
look so young thank God the camera
zoomed in on me and I was up on the big
screen and I looked up I didn't
recognize myself I'm glad you didn't ask
me about this because I want to send it
just like there we were with Pam at the
Ron Robinson store in Santa Monica where
she signed copies of her book raw and
launched panties her line of
eco-friendly
vegan boots mine are made out of
electronics recycled electronics TV
screens phone phone parts and things
wait what yeah so it's recycled
electronics
Pam shows off her boots and a sexy
photoshoot for Coco eco magazine and now
that she has split from Rick Salomon
she's auctioning off her Tiffany
engagement ring and
that they watch a one-piece swimsuit for
charity what inspired you to do that I'm
never gonna wear it again not the ring
anyway I wore the suit a few times I'm
in the shower and saved a key man in my
life just around my house lucky right
and another good bed according to Pam
the single life marriage is hard